vamos a ver si podemos desarrollar
alguna intuición de por qué la ecuación
del equilibrio constante luce de la
forma en lo que lo hace y solo como
repaso vamos a decir que equilibrio
constante ok vamos a ponerlo así
equilibrio constante equilibrio
constante ok esto es igual ok que la
concentración de nuestra molécula james
ok la concentración de nuestra molécula
y ok esto elevado a su respectiva
potencia del coeficiente sem ok esto
elevado a la cem o bueno si estamos
pensando en moles elevado al número de
moles y si pensamos en ellos como una
especie de relación molar o el número de
moles podemos simplemente verlos como la
relación molecular de cualquier manera
por las veces de la concentración de
nuestra
molécula z ok lo voy a poner justos y
ahora date cuenta que no estamos
haciendo algunos cálculos aquí de es
simplemente él
de moles que necesitamos de z por cada
100 moldes de james para obtener bemoles
de x y amo les debe así que esta zeta
está elevada a la potencia de ok y todo
esto está dividido y que vamos a
dividirlo entre la concentración de ven
o que nuestra concentración debe han
elevado a la potencia a que multiplica a
x a la concentración de x elevado
elevado a la potencia a ver esto elevado
a la potencia 20 así que la pregunta es
ok es una bonita y limpia ecuación pero
porque luce de esta forma actualmente
estoy haciendo el vídeo de hecho fue la
mañana de hoy donde empecé a explorar
esta ecuación con logaritmos naturales
creo que puede llegar a algún lado pero
uno de estos comenzó a desmoronarse y
pensé en una forma más simple de
explicar por qué induce d
esta forma así que decidí borrar ese
vídeo porque creo que esta es una forma
mucho más intuitiva de explicar de una
mejor manera porque esto funciona y en
realidad algunas cosas sobre el
equilibrio constante las aprenderemos en
vídeos futuros así que regresando al
punto que es lo que hace que ocurra una
reacción o qué significa el equilibrio
me refiero a la velocidad a la cual la
reacción directa está ocurriendo y lo
puedo poner así a lo cual significa que
la velocidad a la velocidad ok de que
ocurra primero para en este lado ok
vamos a pensarlo de la siguiente manera
que esté sucediendo que absorbe más de
por equis esto se esté transformando se
esté convirtiendo en maceta en maceta y
bueno no hay que olvidar los
coeficientes en seis yemas de bsc está
ok si yo lo que quise a saber es cuál
esta velocidad bueno pues lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que esta velocidad
es exactamente igual a la velocidad de
la reacción inversa y déjeme ponerlo con
otro color a la velocidad a la velocidad
inversa antes de ponerle aquí velocidad
inversa inversa es decir de la reacción
inversa es decir tomarme ahora cbs cbs
yen más de psc está ok y que esto se
transforme en a veces ve más de veces ok
x estas dos velocidades son iguales
cierto esto no necesariamente quiere
decir que las concentraciones son las
mismas ojo porque podríamos tener una
donde terminemos favoreciendo mucho a la
reacción directa en donde terminaríamos
con la mayor concentración de jay-z o
donde podremos favorecer en gran medida
a la reacción inversa donde tenemos más
pero cuando estamos en equilibrio
estamos diciendo que nuestras
concentraciones han alcanzado un punto
estable el cual implica que la velocidad
en la que iremos en esta dirección es
exactamente igual que la velocidad en la
que iremos en esta dirección es decir en
la dirección inversa así que vamos a
pensar sólo un poco sobre qué impulsa
estas velocidades de reacción para que
suceda esta reacción directa que dibuje
aquí en púrpura que necesitamos que
ocurra
bueno pues tenemos que tener
aproximadamente a moléculas de ven y es
más hasta que me ponen las aquí tengo a
moléculas dv
ok vamos a suponer que estas son mis
moléculas deben y preferiblemente
estando en esta misma vecindad
necesitamos de moléculas de x es decir
aquí tenemos de moléculas de x esta es
esta parte de aquí mientras que esto que
está de color azul son esta parte de
aquí ok y además tienen que estar en la
correcta configuración y en él
recto lugar y lo suficientemente cerca y
en orden para que la reacción pase así
que la reacción directa realmente va a
ser impulsada incipiente sobre esto por
la probabilidad de encontrar a moléculas
de b&b moléculas de x todas dentro de la
frontera lo suficientemente cercanas
para que puedan reaccionar entonces
podrías decir que la velocidad va a ser
impulsada y déjame ponerlo con este
color la velocidad va a ser impulsada
tal vez va a ser proporcional vamos a
decir que es igual a alguna constante y
voy a ponerle esa constante cambiamos de
color me gusta este voy a ponerle a esa
constante acá que ojo esa constante cam
tome en cuenta cosas como la temperatura
y como las moléculas están configuradas
porque esto no sólo depende de que estén
ahí debes de tener la preocupación
acerca de su energía cinética y su forma
ya que algunas formas van a ser menos
conductoras para la reacción que a otras
y así que sólo tomaremos en cuenta con
una caja y como estamos hablando de esta
reacción de morado
vamos a llamarle a la cara de la
reacción directa la capa de que la
reacción directa suceda y le voy a poner
un k más debemos detener a moléculas de
b&b moléculas de x así que cuál es la
probabilidad de tener a moléculas de
equis o lo que es lo mismo cuál es una
buena aproximación de esta probabilidad
y bueno la respuesta es la concentración
y déjenme bajar un poco esta pantalla
vamos a pensar de un segundo cuando
escribimos la concentración de la
molécula de y es más déjame ponerlo así
am con este color cuando yo pienso en la
concentración de la molécula bm bueno
aquí tenemos am a veces esta cantidad de
moléculas ve dicho de otra manera esto
esto se da en moles por litro
es entre litro / litro mol entre el
litro ok ahora como sabemos moldes es
sólo un número
así que estos nos dicen miren en algún
volumen dado más o menos cuántas
moléculas esperas encontrar esto es la
concentración
entonces si quería averiguar la
probabilidad de encontrar a de estas
moléculas porque estas zonas que
necesito necesito multiplicar la
concentración de la molécula ven por sí
misma a veces porque necesito a de esta
concentración la probabilidad de tener
sólo una molécula en sólo una pequeña
fracción de espacio entonces eso
requiere la concentración una sola vez
pero necesitamos a veces esta molécula
porque quieres a de estas moléculas aquí
estás de acuerdo y bueno entonces
podríamos ver esto como la probabilidad
de que nos hagan cinco veces cara y
bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que
multiplicar la probabilidad de que nos
haga cara cinco veces así
que la probabilidad de la reacción
directa va a ser la concentración ven ok
nuestra concentración ven elevado a
nuestra potencia
ok y ahora claro esto no es suficiente
para que la concentración suceda a esto
hay que multiplicarlo am y déjenme
cambiar de color también necesitamos ver
de la molécula x así que lo volví a
multiplicar por la concentración de la
molécula x ok esto elevado a la potencia
bien y bueno realmente me gustaría que
estudias 100% seguro de lo que significa
esto estoy diciendo que esto es una
buena aproximación ok esto de aquí o de
hecho es un buen camino para calcular la
probabilidad de escribir esto de este
lado y si yo lo quisiera ver como la
velocidad y la velocidad es igual a
alguna constante acá ok la cual por
cierto recuerda que toma en cuenta la
temperatura y la configuración molecular
por la probabilidad
por la probabilidad que de tener a
moléculas debe a moléculas debe a
moléculas moléculas ok y a su vez y a su
vez ve
x moléculas de moléculas de x mol de q
las justo a eso me refiero
todo esto en un área lo suficientemente
pequeña y todas al mismo tiempo y la
mejor forma de aproximar esto es con la
concentración obviamente a más alta
concentración los moldes por litros más
altos es más probable que encuentres
muchas de las moléculas de esta clase en
este pequeño espacio que te importa y
bueno y la temperatura de la
configuración molecular también te van a
importar pero si usas la concentración
como la probabilidad y déjame cambiar de
color
si utilizas a la concentración como la
probabilidad la probabilidad de obtener
a la molécula de molécula
q la ve en algún volumen dado en algún
volumen ok
lumen
bueno pues es que esto lo podemos ver ok
como la concentración la concentración
de esta molécula ven por el volumen por
el volumen y estos son conceptos de
probabilidad que aprendimos en toda la
lista de probabilidad muy bien y ahora
si queremos la probabilidad de a la
probabilidad de a moléculas de be an
déjame ponerlo así
moléculas debe en algún volumen dado
un volumen volumen bueno pues esto va a
ser igual a algo muy parecido de lo que
tenemos aquí si quieres tener cinco
veces cara a lanzar una moneda esto es
lo mismo que un medio a la quinta
potencia si quieres tener cinco
moléculas aquí bueno cinco de ellas en
el mismo tiempo en algún volumen o en su
dado caso a de ellas esto va a ser a la
concentración del volumen be ok elevado
a la potencia am que multiplica al
volumen ok ahora si también te preocupa
la probabilidad ok déjenme alojar un
poco más la pantalla si nosotros
queremos pensar en la probabilidad en la
probabilidad de obtener a moléculas
moléculas de d
ve moléculas moléculas de x
bueno pues siguiendo en la misma lógica
esto va a ser lo mismo que a la
concentración debe elevado la potencia
que multiplica a la concentración de x
elevado a la potencia de m por el
volumen que ocupen y justo esto es muy
importante porque estoy diciendo ah y
dejen utilizar este color que esto esto
que tiene aquí es la probabilidad
multiplicada por un volumen o dicho de
otra manera la probabilidad de encontrar
el número correcto de partículas y x
partículas en el lugar correcto en algún
volumen va a ser proporcional
proporcional a la concentración de x de
la concentración debe y estamos diciendo
y dejen subir ahora un poco la pantalla
justo esto lo voy a utilizar porque
estamos diciendo que la velocidad de
reacción directa es también proporcional
a esto que tenemos acá
de color azul esto es donde tenemos la
velocidad de reacción directa es igual a
la concentración de nuestras moléculas
de elevado a la potencia y x elevado a
la potencia de ok por una cierta
constante es proporcional ahora si
queremos encontrar la velocidad inversa
y voy a poner que esta es mi velocidad
directa directa porque si quiero pensar
en la velocidad inversa y dejen utilizar
este color la velocidad inversa y
inversa ok como se va a ver
bueno pues pensando en acá arriba
déjenme subir un poco la pantalla
si yo pienso en justo lo que tenemos
aquí la velocidad inversa se va a ver de
la siguiente manera una cierta constante
acá y esta vez le voy a poner acá menos
para no confundirnos no precisamente es
la misma constante pero mantenemos la
misma lógica y ahora como vamos en
dirección contraria si vemos la ecuación
original ésta que tenemos aquí podemos
ver que es muy parecido solamente que
con diferentes
de modo que la reacción inversa va a ser
la concentración de james y déjame
ponerlo con este color a base de la
concentración de james ok elevado a la
potencia ce ok que multiplica a la
concentración de z elevado a la potencia
de ahora como al inicio de vídeo dijimos
y déjeme subir un poco la pantalla para
que lo veas
acá arriba dijimos que esto se tenía que
cumplir es decir que como estamos en el
equilibrio una velocidad es igual a la
otra justo lo que tenemos aquí entonces
puedo decir y déjame ver un poco la
pantalla vamos a utilizar esto de aquí y
déjame borrar esto que tenemos acá abajo
si borramos todo esto que tenemos aquí
déjame quitarlo de aquí ok y déjame
rellenar esto con color negro ok ahora
si nos fijamos en esta parte como
dijimos que las velocidades son iguales
entonces yo puedo escribir que esto es
igual a esto de aquí y déjame ponerlo
así yo puedo decir que hamas ok es decir
la velocidad de la reacción directa que
multiplica a la concentración de esta
molécula bm elevado a la potencia que a
su vez multiplica a la concentración de
la molécula x elevado a la potencia de
donde recuerda que que más se tomó en
cuenta por la temperatura y la
estructura molecular y todo eso y bueno
toda esta probabilidad del volumen
también está reducido aquí en el factor
cam y esto va ser igual a la velocidad
de la reacción de inversa que es justo
la que tenemos aquí y es más déjenme
atraparla ok y la voy a copiar y pegar
porque la voy a poner aquí y voy a decir
que estas dos son
iguales ok esto es exactamente igual a
esto esto porque estamos en el
equilibrio ahora si dividimos ambos
lados entre acá - y ambos lados entre
esta parte que tengo aquí ok que me va a
quedar bueno que camas camas entre a y
déjeme ponerlo así entre acá - entre
cada menos esto lo voy a ver como a
estas dos velocidades y déjenme
atraparlas con este aquí esto a esto
copiar y pegar ok lo voy a tener acá ok
lo voy a dividir a esto lo voy a dividir
entre estas concentraciones que tengo
aquí y es más también las voy a atrapar
y las voy a pegar aquí abajo la
concentración debe elevado a la potencia
a que multiplica a la concentración de x
elevado a la potencia p y justo ahora
como estas dos son constantes
arbitrarias las puedo reemplazar por
otro
el nombre de la constante de equilibrio
la constante de equilibrio que qué creés
es justo a lo que queríamos llegar justo
lo que tenemos aquí arriba y es en donde
empezamos queríamos llegar a ver cómo
podríamos representar esta ecuación que
tengo aquí ahora sé que esto es
demasiada cuentita pero lo que menos
quiero es que pienses que todo esto no
viene afuera de lo azul y esto yo quiero
pensar que es intuición esta formula
realmente que la probabilidad es como ya
vimos esto es la probabilidad de la
velocidad de la reacción directa
proporcional a eso mismo porque mientras
más concentración de moléculas tienes es
más probable que lo encuentres ahora si
necesitas más de estas moléculas
alrededor vas a tener que multiplicar
esta concentración por cada otra porque
la probabilidad va a ser más baja porque
necesitas más de ellos juntos para que
la reacción suceda y esa misma cosa para
todos
en la fórmula pero todo esto todo esto
fue derivado de la reacción directa
justo lo que tenemos la parte de acá
abajo
ok lo cual debes decir igual alguna
constante por la reacción inversa justo
esto que tenemos acá arriba ok o de
hecho sus velocidades deberían de ser
iguales pero cuando calcular la
probabilidad deberás tener una constante
hay esta constante como sea
espero no haberlos confundido pero sólo
quería decirles que esto no es sólo una
ecuación aleatoria realmente pienso que
esto viene de la realidad de que si
tienes mayor concentración es más la
probabilidad que tienes de que las
moléculas actuales choquen entre sí